Antonio rüdiger looked in dominant form
at the start of Germany's training
session but as the crowd watched on
disaster struck for the defender rüdiger
was left holding his right knee
following a collision with Thomas Muller
a blow for yo him live in the German
squad it later emerged that rüdiger had
torn a ligament in his knee and will
miss all of Euro 2016 it's a bitter loss
because rüdiger was the backup for mats
Hummels who's recovering from an injury
himself until then the atmosphere was
relaxed in AV on some 2,000 spectators
watched the first training session the
only one during the tournament which
will be open to the public many locals
and tourists from Germany sat in the
stands fans here are optimistic about
the team's chances Richmond scientist
trunk it looks very good so far very
easygoing but they still have to work
hard because it's very warm I think the
guys are very well prepared and
hopefully they can win the european
championship in 12 interesting tickle
war coach love has called up
Leverkusen's yonatan tah as a
replacement for rüdiger he'll join up
with the squad before Germany's first
match on Sunday